alors les gars drucker on va faire une
nouvelle interview pour source je suis
flatté elle est pour vous celle là enfin
vous essuyer les plâtres ouais c'est
l'interview docteur jekyll et mister
hyde
charles bouchard
pendant les géniales on peut bouger
beaucoup c'est fort quand même de mener
cette carrière sans avoir trop utiliser
le nom de vos oncles
écoutez je trouve ça normal je crois que
j'avais d'abord envie de
comment dire d'être crédible à leurs
yeux donc je vois pas comment j'aurais
été prise au sérieux si je suis avait
commencé a alors demandé des choses et
puis je crois que ça se passe pas comme
ça par rapport
aux gens ce métier je crois qu'on se
fait respecter autrement que en passant
des coups de fil
ah c'est vrai on
dirait hulk
vous savez bien les rückert que si les
médias s'intéressent à vous c'est aussi
pour ça mais ça je suis d'accord je suis
tout à fait consciente que c'est quelque
chose qui attire la curiosité d'un autre
côté les médias il arrive depuis cette
pièce surtout parce que ça fait dix ans
que j'ai dans ce métier j'ai fait des
rôles secondaires détruits on n'a jamais
vraiment parlé de moi sauf une ou deux
fautes ou deux articles d'ailleurs qui
était pas bien brillant en ce qu'il veut
de ma part mais sinon
ça arrive surtout depuis cette pièce
depuis ce film parce que j'ai un rôle
principal dans un film
a toujours donné de bons conseils et moi
par exemple sur les sur les sucres lents
sur les pattes par exemple les jours
d'émission maintenant je mange des pâtes
merci michel pas encore de vélo mais
quels conseils vous adonner michel
drucker
michel il me donne surtout moi en fait
il me donne pas des conseils de plan de
carrière ou deux trucs comme ça peuvent
sur l'artistique et il me conseille
absolument pas là dessus dans un temps
il ment riant sans fin comme c'est
quelqu'un d'assez droit humainement il
ment rien sur ce truc là quoi par
rapport aux médias ou être comme ça
c'est quelqu'un qui respecte plus les
relations humaines que le calcul vous y
avez dit que vous veniez ici ce soir
bien sûr je dit d'y aller
oui il m'a dit de venir mais il vous
regarde
au fond les a vous savez que chez
drucker il est pas si gentil que ça
parce que sinon ils seraient pas là
depuis toutes ces années oui mais dieu
merci ils disent aussi sa vie
professionnelle de sa vie familiale donc
ça j'ai pas accès à cet aspect là de lui
et tant mieux j'ai pas du tout envie de
moi personnellement je préfère croire
que non et je suis convaincu que non
mais vous vous savez plus fort vous
savez mieux que moi comment ça se passe
dans le milieu de la télévision je viens
c'est parce que ni le juge halphen
michel a vu le film oui il l'a trouvée
formidable
ça c'est gildas non il l'a trouvé
exceptionnel
qu'est ce qui vous a dit en sortant du
film
écoutez je me souviens plus par rapport
au film me souviens par rapport à la
pièce qu'il avait été très touché et
tout ça mais je vous avoue que j'ai pas
eu cette conversation là avec lui par
rapport aux filles pour le moment il a
vu la pièce deux fois il a vu d'autres
trucs un peu plus obscurs que j'ai fait
mais par rapport aux fils je sais qu'il
a vu je sais mais je on n'en a pas parlé
aux films quand même à léa drucker
c'est quand même un peu du théâtre filmé
non ben oui y'a des gens qui pensent que
c'est du théâtre filmé oui c'est assez
le parti pris du metteur en scène aussi
de garder une espèce de réalité parce
que c'est ça ressemble c'est une pièce
quand vous la lisez qui est à l'origine
qui se passe dans le bronx et tout ça
était assez âpre et dur qui est violente
mais il ya une part de poésie et john
pepper voulait garder un côté
théâtral avec des décors en studio et et
voilà c'est voulu ah oui je pense qu'on
signe
vous avez été dans nominé aux molières
pour roberta votre rôle dans papillons
de nuit est-ce que ça a été le plus
grand moment de votre vie non non j'ai
été très très heureuse dans la mine et
gta très flatté la soirée en elle même
j'ai pas trouvé ça super agréable moi
c'est un peu assez assez impressionnant
et un stressant et moi j'étais un peu
paumée
mais c'est vrai que c'est flatteur
à part maintenant
un moment de ma vie
j'ai un souvenir d'enfance très fort je
pense pas que ce soit le plus grand
moment de ma vie mais j'essaie quand
j'ai découvert des patinoires
les modèles patineuse je suis peut-être
comédienne parce que j'ai raté ma
carrière de patineuse oui oui je voulais
deux patineuses et j'ai dit voilà j'ai
vu mon père mes parents m'ont emmené
dans un espace de parts qu'il y avait
une patinoire en plein air et et je
crois que c'est un des moments les plus
beaux de ma vie ouais il est sympa
candeloro je ne connais pas
et vous je vous demande pas nombre
d'allées partie
c'est pas sympa pour nous présenter
parce que c'est
franchement c'est en ce moment à saint
sernin difficile moi j'espère que la
reddition et manque plus que télérama et
j'arrête
[Applaudissements]
onze films 11 ans de carrière puis vint
c'est pas tellement connu peut-être
parce que
d'abord je change de tronche un peu tout
le temps les trucs que je fais je
ressens je ressens que jamais à la même
chose
parce que j'ai fait beaucoup de rôles
secondaires et puis que c'est peuvent
pas je veux dire c'est pas forcément les
personnes ce qui attire le plus
attention j'ai fait des pièces en
banlieue qui était pas forcément
médiatisé mais qui était pas moins
intéressante
voilà ça vous manque de quoi la
notoriété cette attitude
non c'est juste que on en a un peu
besoin pour exister dans ce métier
[Musique]
aujourd'hui lna vous êtes en train de
devenir une icône de la scène
underground c'est plutôt agréable non
ouais ça va je peux je me plains pas ça
me plaît je préfère la queue qu'ailleurs
lna thierry michaud le fait d'avoir été
la soeur de lio ça vous a aidé quand
même oh le méchant je suis toujours
si ça m'a aidé et je oui ou non je sais
pas peut-être qu'on ouvre les portes
plus facilement mais quand on aime ou
pas plus sympa mieux écouter il faut
faire ses preuves quand même on a le
sentiment
elena que vous êtes trouvé musicalement
aujourd'hui
oui c'est vrai que je suis plus
confortable dans cet album
ce sont des chansons douces joué par un
trio de jazz et voilà je trouvais j'ai
trouvé les crains qu'il me fallait elena
pourquoi si peu de disques en quinze ans
j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup de chansons
dont je suis pas forcément fier des fois
je les réécoute me dit c'est bien que ça
soit pas sorti non plus tu dois
t'éclater sous la douche voilà et puis
j'ai fait plein de maquettes jets privés
j'ai proposé où ils ont dit ce que
d'etats détail de deux morceaux mais ça
peut faire peser passe voilà vous êtes
très joli
vous adorez faire l'amour
alors pourquoi avoir choisi un mec aussi
peu sexy que
non parce que tu es marié en plus je
suis pas d'accord je trouve que c'est
il ressemble à jim morrison
new bond m'a dit que je ressemblais à
jimi hendrix avec des cheveux noirs oui
c'est vrai bon bah écoute c'est qu'une
fois hélas oui faites moi un beau
sourire
n'est pas forcément
facile ce masque en fait - et les masses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on commence par le docteur jekyll
ou vous êtes aristo mais vous n'avez pas
gardé leur iguane si vous appelez votre
annoncé hélène rey guen de fougerolles
voilà non puis bon vous avez pas d pas
été élevé trop cateau et pour une pour
une noble en fait vous êtes assez cool
non je m'attends à ne lâcher parce que
ouais ouais ouais ouais non je suis pas
né avec une cuillère en argent dans la
bouche je suis plutôt voilà quoi
non mais j'ai une petite éducation à mon
avis qui fait que je peux être poli en
même temps avec les trois mois et demi
que j'ai passé avec les garçons je
connais des mots vachement
voilà j'ai pas trop la ramener parce que
j'ai peur de ce qui arrive après vas-y
pourtant j'ai quand même un air un look
ont une allure pas très populaire c'est
pas un handicap pour votre carrière
honnêtement moi je m'en rends pas compte
d'eux si on voit tout de suite élaine
deveault la particule si elle vient tout
de suite j'ai pas l'impression d'avoir
eu des rôles forcément grâce ou à cause
de ça de ségonzac je pense que ça a bien
aidés mais ça m'a bien arrangé et sinon
je pense que je suis j'ai l'air assez
accessible les gens me disent pas et
j'ai l'air trop bourgeoise vous êtes
content bureau là vous avez bien sorti
ouais ouais non j'ai adoré tourner ce
truc là surtout de faire un genre de
james bond indiana jones tomb raider en
france ouais ouais super content tu
fous là c'est pas gênant d'être
découvertes travers un film aussi
baroque que laurette vous auriez pas
préféré devenir star avec tavernier par
exemple mais qu'est ce qui vous dit que
je vais devenir star la tiens semblait
encore galérait dix ans
donc on verra j'ai l'impression que je
fais mon petit chemin tranquille ou quoi
qu'est si on affiche 69 c'est vous qui
me poser une question à l'aise en
déplacement
j'ai plein de questions à la la la alors
avant
quel est le moment où vous à vignes de
plus le plus honte dans votre vie si le
jour je me suis fait choper pour avoir
photocopié six pages dans un bouquin
j'avais honte de moi je l'avais écrite
292 et
commerces qui s'y passe
ça vous va faire maintenant vous êtes
populaire vous pensez ça y est vous êtes
passés de l'autre côté parce que vous
avez longtemps attendu de faire un gros
film comme ça ouais ouais bah en même
temps je recherche pas forcément être
populaire j'aimerais être populeux fin à
faire un gros truc qui cartonne
pourraient avoir accès à des films mais
des rôles qui m'intéresserait peut-être
plus en même temps en ce moment ça va
mieux je suis sur des trucs que j'ai le
choix puisque avant j'ai envie de dire
alors tout le monde commence à connaître
hélène de fougerolles pourtant souvent
on vous appelle encore anne-marie
way we bain marie c'était dans le
collège descartes brisé n'est ce pas non
ça veut dire m'a appelé anne marie
pendant cinq ans et là
c'était fini c'est qu'on vous parle
encore de malaisie
[Musique]
le petit billet et 6 rouges ciblons si
bons qu'ils donnent du plaisir même à
ceux qui ne mangent pas
souvent
pour moi que nous ont pas ou finalement
je vais arrêter alors
alors vous êtes une fille sexy moderne
sans préjugés vous avez doublé un film
porno pour que l'api je vais passer des
vacances au cap d'agde
le court métrage pour notre klapisch
c'était j'étais d'accord capté que
j'étais un peu surprise ouais vous êtes
resté quatre jours quand même ouais les
particuliers prendre goût ça n'a pas
fonctionné je me suis paré de son fils
comme ça dans la vraie vie des trucs
hallucinants j'ai appris plein de trucs
c'est quoi cette nature il se serait
fait semblant pas connaître jésus mais
je voulais vérifier être sûr
il ya un problème quand même vous
refusez de vous déshabiller dans les
films c'est normal je laisse à une fois
pour un téléfilm et cgt très moche très
mal filmée je me suis pas senti je me
suis dit pourquoi j'ai accepté voilà
c'était mal faible donc depuis
maintenant je me méfie j'ai pas envie
j'aime pas ça ça me fait pas plaisir et
à part besson car il rappelé et à me
[ __ ] à poil
hélène de fougerolles à une vie privée
magnifique
cet
art aux minettes à une ville magnifique
c'est vrai quand on vous voit tous les
deux choisir vos tomates au jardin du
marais on dit quel beau couple
si on va vite quand on va au pressing le
samedi matin à la laverie du temple on
pense qu'il est heureux l'air très
heureux en tous les cas
c'est rare dans le métier non ma vie
privée se passe très très bien mais
c'est pas un problème que les magazines
people et rien à se mettre sous la dent
dernièrement ils ont vu un truc à se
mettre sous la dent moi en vacances avec
le père de robbie l'aip on va dire et
bah écoutez c'est ce que c'est je sais
pas c'est que
j'en sais rien soit ils sont dit on va
pas vendre un truc avec ça si vous
trompez pas vous ferez pas la une des
journaux people en soit c'est avec une
pop star ni rien qu' on est plutôt j'ai
pas envie de m'afficher je parle pas de
ma vie privée parce que c'est ce que
j'ai le plus beau dans ma vie et que
j'ai pas envie qu'on me la bim donc que
je le garde pour moi voilà l'amour c'est
ce qui est le plus beau
imaginez en train de vous dire non je
penserai pourquoi
vous connaissez la chanson aimer c'est
ce qu'il ya de plus beau pour n'est pas
obligé non avant et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de il a l'habitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux